Traduttore: Andrea Giglio
Revisore: Marco Caresia
Cibo, spreco, zero: tre parole
per fare una rivoluzione,
almeno forse per avere una visione,
una visione sul futuro
e un'azione sul presente, oggi.
Cosa possiamo fare?
Be’, intanto partiamo dalle parole, forse
abusate, ma mettiamo insieme, proviamo.
Cibo: quattro lettere.
Durante Expo ne abbiamo
sentito parlare tanto,
forse non sappiamo più cos’è.
Se fate un elenco di aggettivi che usiamo
correntemente, capite che il cibo alto,
il cibo basso, il cibo giusto,
il cibo ingiusto, il cibo sprecato,
il cibo scialacquato, il cibo...
il cibo spadellato...
Ne troviamo tantissimi
e sono tutti delle dicotomie,
delle polarizzazioni,
tanto che non sappiamo più
se siamo bulimici, anoressici,
se siamo grassi, se siamo magri,
spendiamo di più per metterci a dieta
che per mangiare, almeno nel nostro paese,
e siamo disorientati: non sappiamo più
che il cibo serve per vivere,
è un bisogno primario, senza cibo
non si vive e nel cibo c'è l'acqua,
perchè l'acqua che usiamo
per produrre il cibo, gli alimenti,
è nel mondo l'80%, che viene utilizzata.
Quindi quando mangiamo, in realtà
non lo sappiamo, beviamo,
come ci insegna il maestro Altan.
Eppure, in queste quattro lettere,
noi dobbiamo ritrovare l’essenza,
la vera essenza del cibo
che viene anche sprecato.
Cibo, spreco.
Se ne spreca tantissimo,
non ce ne rendiamo conto
perché noi non diamo, forse,
più valore a questo cibo.
Tanto cibo ancora buono finisce nel bidone
della spazzatura nelle nostre case.
In Italia, se mettiamo assieme la filiera
dal campo alla forchetta,
dal campo alla tavola e tutti i passaggi
che servono per portare il cibo
nelle nostre case, la produzione agricola,
la trasformazione dell’industra,
la distribuzione grande, piccola,
i mercati all'ingrosso,
fino alla ristorazione... Facciamo cento.
Cinquanta si perde per tante ragioni
nelle fasi commerciali.
Il resto, cinquanta, metà, a casa nostra.
Il cibo che finisce però nel bidone
della spazzatura ancora buona:
questo è lo spreco,
ma lo definirò meglio dopo
È qualcosa che non si può recuperare,
diventa rifiuto e nel momento
in cui rifiutiamo qualcosa
che ancora buono,
qualcosa che ha un difetto estetico,
che ha una scadenza ravvicinata,
è perché abbiamo paura,
perché siamo insicuri.
E il passo poi per rifiutare l'altro,
il diverso
- e nella nostra società qui siamo -
è un attimo, l'abbiamo già fatto.
Eppure lo spreco, se ti poni nell'ottica
di poterlo recuperare o addirittura,
meglio ancora, di prevenirlo,
diventa un'occasione,
diventa un'opportunità.
È strana questa parola così negativa,
abusata forse come il cibo,
la sentiamo ripetere ripetere ripetere
si spreca tutto:
il tempo, la vita, il cibo naturalmente.
Però proviamo a vedere
qual è l'opportunità.
Dividiamola in due questa parola,
in due parti,
quasi fosse una sillabazione,
una grammatica, un lessico
che dobbiamo ricostruire,
forse anche nella nostra testa.
E c'è una parte negativa, la prima: “spr”.
Ci mettiamo un meno,
una piccola formula, semplice.
È la parte del rifiuto, della spazzatura,
che dobbiamo ridurre.
In effetti, forse, ce n’è troppa.
E se alla montagna di spazzatura
che ci circonda aggiungiamo gli sprechi,
prodotti ancora buoni
che finiscono nella spazzatura,
be’, poi non ne usciamo più.
Questo bisogna che lo riduciamo,
che mettiamo un meno davanti.
Ma poi c'è una grande opportunità,
perché c'è la seconda parte
della stessa parola: “eco”.
È una radice, è una casa, qualcosa
che si richiama, che rimbalza.
Ma ci sono due “eco”,
in questa visione che vi voglio proporre.
C’è un “eco” piccola,
che è la nostra casa, l'economia.
Sì, l’economia è una casa:
dentro c'è la nostra vita,
c’è la famiglia, c'è il cibo,
ci sono le relazioni,
ci sono i nostri vestiti,
c'è tutto quello che facciamo.
C’è un tetto, importante averla,
ma anche nel suo significato
di risparmiare, fare economia,
dobbiamo renderci conto che questa casa
sta dentro in una casa più grande.
E l'ecologia è un’altra casa,
è la stessa radice, solo che è più grande
perché deve contenere
delle risorse naturali.
L'acqua, l'energia, il suolo.
E a cosa servono poi
queste risorse naturali, limitate?
Per produrre il cibo, se siamo in grado,
e lo siamo, di combinarle al meglio
con la nostra sapienza di agricoltori,
di contadini, di imprenditori agricoli,
che mettono insieme le conoscenze
per far arrivare l'alimento
dal campo alla tavola.
Eppure noi sappiamo dalla fisica
che le risorse naturali sono limitate,
si rinnovano nel tempo;
forse dovremmo lasciare il tempo
a queste risorse di rinnovarsi.
Il suolo, questo strato di settanta
centimetri che è la pelle della terra.
L'acqua, l’energia, quella rinnovabile.
E allora se la vediamo così,
la casa grande, be’,
non ha senso pensare che la casa piccola,
la casa domini, sovrasti la casa grande.
Allora, in questa visione di spreco
e di opportunità, troviamo un percorso:
vedere la casa piccola all’interno
dei limiti della casa più grande.
E questo vuol dire rispostare
i limiti delle risorse naturali,
riguardare il nostro modello di sviluppo
che è sempre in avanti però è lineare.
Questa crescita dove
devi produrre, produrre, produrre
e quindi consumare, consumare, consumare
e dunque anche sprecare.
Cos'è la rottamazione?
Esaurire un prodotto
prima che sia davvero finito.
Allora, in questa visione di spreco
divisa in due parti,
dove “eco” è il futuro, la sostenibilità,
durare nel tempo,
rivediamo una sfida che è quella
del nostro tempo e non solo del futuro:
di vedere l'economia circolare,
dove quello che è rifiuto di una risorsa
diventa bene per un'altra specie,
dove gli animali - e lo vediamo
nell'economia della natura -
non mangiano le risorse
che hanno a disposizione,
altrimenti non sopravvivono;
dove non c'è disoccupazione.
Ma torniamo alla terza parola: lo zero.
È un obiettivo in realtà,
che numero al minimo un obiettivo alto.
Allora in questa visione di tre parole,
qual è il nostro futuro?
Riuscire a combinarle.
Cibo, spreco, zero.
Cos'è il cibo, cos’è lo spreco,
cosè lo zero.
Riusciamo a capire che il percorso
che abbiamo davanti
ci porta a due azioni fondamentali
che sono:
quello di recuperare tutto il cibo
in eccesso, in surplus,
che non viene venduto
e che non si può fare
un'azione preventiva.
E quindi la straordinarietà del recupero
attraverso il dono di chi produce qualcosa
di più non riesce a venderelo,
non riesce a collocarlo sul mercato
e chi invece ha bisogno.
Allora anche l'economia
nella sua circolarità riscopre un valore
che è di relazione:
nel momento in cui metti a fattor comune,
metti in legame chi ha un eccedenza
e chi ha una carenza,
chi può donare un prodotto alimentare
e chi può riceverlo.
Poichè non hai bisogno di prezzi,
non hai bisogno del mercato,
attivi una relazione.
E quel bene che recuperi
diventa relazionale.
È questa la visione sul futuro:
immettere nell'economia qualcosa
che sembra esterno
ma che è sempre stato lì,
e pensare che nei valori
che siamo abituati a utilizzare
anche mentalmente
- il valore di scambio, il valore d'uso,
scambio un prodotto, lo uso,
mangio, bevo, mi vesto -
c'è un valore di relazione
che viene attraverso il dono.
Ed è questo il primo passo
che dobbiamo fare:
pensare che l'economia può essere diversa,
circolare e anche gratuita, di relazione.
E allora lo spreco diventa un'opportunità.
Eppure c'è un altra azione preventiva
da fare, la conosciamo dalla medicina:
la prevenzione.
Non arrivare allo spreco: è quello
che ci dice l'Europa,
oltre all'economia circolare.
Il miglior rifiuto
e quindi migliore spreco
è quello che non produci,
è quello che non fai.
E per fare prevenzione abbiamo bisogno
di un aggettivo del cibo che abbiamo perso
in questa polarizzazione, in questa
dicotomia, dove siamo grassi e magri,
dove siamo bulimici e anoressici,
dove spadelliamo
da tutte le parti in tivù.
Avete in mente tutti gli chef
che sfrigolano, che sfilettano,
che spadellano da tutte le parti,
non facendo cosa?
Quello che ci serve per la prevenzione
dello spreco e di tanto altro,
ridare valore al cibo.
E cioè l'educazione alimentare.
È questo il cibo che, nella visione-azione
cibo, spreco, zero, dev'essere educato.
Educare cosa vuol dire?
Tirare fuori, per mettere
dentro qualcosa di buono,
ridando valore al cibo.
Ed ecco allora che quello scarto,
quel rifiuto,
in quel processo di disintegrazione
che è la nostra società,
che si può identificare
con il rifiuto dell'altro,
dobbiamo tornare a scuola
ed è questa la sfida.
E io oso proporvela con coraggio.
Perché se siamo in più,
forse otterremo il risultato.
Dobbiamo rimettere l’educazione
alimentare nelle nostre scuole,
mi viene da dire di ogni ordine
e grado come fossero dei capitoli
- l’educazione alimentare -
della nostra educazione civica,
o come si dice oggi alla cittadinanza:
ripartire dal cibo, per ridargli valore,
consideralo un diritto garantito:
se non mangi non vivi.
Rispettando l'identità, l'origine.
E come sono composte oggi
le nostre classi?
Sono composte da, diciamo,
delle derivazioni del multi:
multietniche, multireligiose, multi-paese.
E allora è attraverso il cibo,
riscoprendo il suo valore
e rispettandolo nelle culture diverse
che si può fare integrazione.
È utopia? È una visione sul futuro
che si potrebbe realizzare?
Io non lo so.
Ma so che la scuola,
l’educazione alimentare,
so che il riconsiderare il cibo
come un valore, è il nostro presente.
Certo, gli studenti, i ragazzi,
gli alunni guardano oltre,
in una visione di sostenibilità
che poi è un patto fra generazioni.
Ma noi dobbiamo ottenere
dei risultati subito,
altrimenti il mondo va troppo avanti
e tornare indietro non sarà più possibile.
Allora è da qui che dobbiamo ripartire
e dobbiamo chiederlo, dobbiamo osare.
Perché nessuno ci risponde, nessuno lo fa,
tutti parlano, parlano, parlano,
cibo, cibo, cibo,
e poi rimane tutto lì,
nel bidone della spazzatura.
E cos’è un'utopia?
Per arrivare, diciamo, a una visione
che ci può coinvolgere tutti.
Io la vedo come quella straordinaria frase
che scrisse un tempo Eduardo Galeano
e che forse qualcuno di voi avrà letto.
È un orizzonte.
Intanto lo devi vedere, e io lo declino
in tre parole: cibo, spreco, zero.
Ma la rivoluzione culturale è un attimo,
basta poco a vedere questo orizzonte.
Perché. se ci pensate, la stessa “cultura”
cambiando una vocale diventa “coltura”,
l’“alimento” diventa “elemento”,
il “corrotto” diventa “corretto”.
È questa la rivoluzione che io voglio,
non è tanto distante.
Quanti passi devo fare?
Cento.
Incomincio a camminare
e faccio cento passi.
Come sono arrivato a quell'orizzonte,
lo vedo lo sento, si sposta ancora.
Altri cento passi.
E io li faccio.
E continuo ad andare in quella direzione,
a cambiare le vocali, le consonanti,
a vedere come fare.
Ma dipende da me.
E intanto cammino, e si sposta
di altri dieci passi.
Forse, diciamo, è un po' più vicina.
Intanto cos'è successo?
Be’, io sto camminando, camminate con me.
Grazie.
[Applausi]